female narrator: Expanding to
new markets around the world
is a great way to find new users
and increase your revenue.
We've gathered ten tips
developers have used
to be truly local
while they go global
in order to find success.
Many of these tips
apply to apps too.
Going global starts with the
design of your game's code
and its screen layouts.
Allow for variations in
language, sentence structure,
characters,
and number presentations
that you'll encounter
when localizing.
For example, building in 30%
extra space in UI elements
will help avoid issues
in other languages.
Store all the content
you'll change when localizing
in a resource file
so you don't have to recode
when you localize.
Use system provided formats
for dates, times,
numbers, and currencies
so your app automatically
matches the user's selection.
Cheap, reliable data connections
aren't yet available
to everyone.
A game that continues to run
without a data connection
can dramatically increase
its potential audience.
Make your game's installation
package as small as possible.
Users sometimes skip
installing big games
due to device memory
or bandwidth concerns.
Understand your audience and
everything that matters to them.
Look out for significant
cultural differences,
game characters, levels,
or scenarios
that could possible jar
with local sensitivities.
Look out for local interests
in specific game genres--
casual games
featuring cute characters
do well in Japan and Korea,
for instance,
whereas war strategy games
are big in Germany and Russia.
Look out for how local users
pay for games
and in-app content.
If carrier billing is common,
monthly limits might affect
how many and how often
users make in-app purchases.
There are many common
expectations
among Western markets.
Here, users are more engaged
by simple character-based
game icons without words;
prefer screenshots
showing actual gameplay;
like to get started quickly and
discover new features gradually;
and a deep meta-game can keep
them coming back,
respond to item prices
ending in .99.
There are also many common
expectations
among Eastern markets.
For example, in Japan
users like casual games
to have icons with cute,
colorful characters
in the anime and manga styles,
but more hardcore game's icons
should reflect
their game's theme;
prefer colorful screenshots
that illustrate game world
content and theme;
engage with casual games with
a fairly steep learning curve;
expect app prices
to end in zero;
often preregister to get in-game
items as rewards.
Consider this a starting point
for your own research.
You should try to engage
a professional third-party
app translation service
or even your local fans
to do a high-quality translation
of your app.
You can also make use
of the app translation service
in the developer console.
Simply send your original text
in resource files.
You don't need to amend
your development processes
to accommodate the translator.
You should also add
your Play Store listing text
so that, too, can be localized.
Testing is still essential
because even small translation
errors can prove embarrassing
and no matter how good your
internalization efforts are,
they may leave some text
truncated
or incorrectly formatted.
Test via locals.
Reach out to
your user community.
You'll find a wealth
of language skills
and local knowledge there.
A localized app
needs localized marketing.
Local marketing can include
a localized store listing,
support from local
user community members,
spreading the word in their
language on global social media
and local channels, too,
a localized press pack sent out
to key media and bloggers,
and localized ad campaigns
to kick-start local installs
and boost local launches.
Users like to get a good idea
of a game's gameplay
before they install it.
Adding a trailer
to your Play Store listing
will help them decide.
When you're creating a trailer,
make sure you create
market-specific versions.
Highlight features of the game
that will hold
most local appeal,
go for a localized voiceover,
or use translated subtitles
if you can't.
The developer console
automatically translates
Google Play reviews
so you can read reviews
from users around the world.
Respond to these users.
Let them know
their opinions matter
and how you're incorporating
their feedback.
Users will appreciate the effort
if you can respond
in their language.
You can also use beta testing
to test your game
and game's localization
with enthusiastic users
in a specific country
before launching more widely.
For more information
on localizing your app
and launching in local markets,
head over
to the distribute section
of the Android developer
website.
If you want more tips
on how to improve your app
or game's performance
and build a better app business,
check out the other videos
in this series
and download The Secrets
to App Success on Google Play.